για ώρα που θα χρειαστης το μάθημα να το αξιοποιήσουν γιατί είμαστε πολύ κοντάσκαι χρήση
της τεχνολογίας πολύ θετική παρόλα αυτά φαίνεται από όλες τις έρευνες ότι τρο να το
έχουν μαζί τους ενεργοποιημένο τους αποσπάτι προσοχή και στο μάθημα αλλά και στο διάλημμα τα
από μονώνει τα παιδιά για τα αποξενώνοι ήταν αλήθεια όλα αυτά που λέύονταν ότι μάθητές
επαανστιχήματα η επαιρναν τηλέφωνον για να γλητώσουμε ένανδιαγώνισμα με απιλές γιαβόμβες κι ότί δήποτε για
αυτό σας προβλημάτησε το θεματων κινή των τηλεφωνο όχι μόνο γι αυτό αυτά θα ήτανμε
μονομένα περιστατικά εξάλλουν μας προβλημάτησε όπως και όλιντην ευρώπι και όλον των κόσμομια γιατί και
οι αμερικοί και ο καναδάς προχωρούν στα ίδια μέτρα μας προβλημάτησε λόγο των δε δομένουν
που έχουμε από τις διεθνεις έρευνες ότιών τους επηρεάζετη ψυχική τους ιγείαγκυρίως αλλά και της
σωματική τους και την ραση τους και είχαν παρατηρηθεί και κρουσβαταστιγκή προψυχικής ιγείας ιδικά η
υπηρεσία εκπαιδευτικής ψυχολογίας μας με βασην τα δεδομένα που έχει ήταν ιδιαίτερααν ησυχιανησυχητική συνεπώς έπρεπε
να λάβουμε δράση και ήταν και μια δράσεη που αναλάβαμε μαζί μετις υπόλιπες χωρές της
ευρώπης δεν περιμέναμε δηλαδή όπως άλλα πράγματα να ακολουθήσουμε εδώ είμαστε πρωτοπόρι μαζί με άλλες
χώρες της ευρώπης και ήταν το πιο ακραοφθανόμενο παρατηρήθηκε επιχητία σας και αφορούσε τα κινητά
τηλεφνωομίζω όπως ήταν αυτό που αναφέρεται πριν με στιχήματα αυτό δεν το περίμέναμε όπως φαίνεται
κάποια παιδιά ιδικά κάποια παιδιά που έχουν και μιαν οικονομική άνεση στην οικογένεια τους είχαν
πρόσβαση και στις κάρτες των κγονέον τους ηλεκτρονικά συνεπως το ζήσαμε και αυτό δυστυχώς πότε
είναι ένας άλλω εθισμός πολύ σοβαρός ον τζόγος ε ο ηλεκτρονικός τζόγος και για αυτό
έχουμε και την υπηρεσία που ασχολύτημα αυτά τα θέματα μείς έχουμε βάλει ίδι αποφέτος προγράμματα
από την προσχολική γιατς